too I think like women are just fat
today yeah which is nice which women
like which most women like to be fat
rather than
slim now you see
do you think yeah
they like they like okay a big butt with
a small waist that's not fair yeah you
can't have a big that's a small waist
without surgery but this one here she's
got a great shape she's she's got big
butts small waist naturally is is it
depends on your state yeah
I mean most women like to be
bigger now nowadays rather than deemed
skinny maybe they pretend they're happy
because there's body positivity I'm
happy big girl's life is just amazing
it's been as big as Lisa or yeah
she happy okay let me ask you let me let
me she's making money one to ten what do
you rank lizzo one to ten ten
um
do you really think she's cries on
Instagram live oh I don't know that much
about her I just know I see her
do you genuinely okay do you genuinely
think she's happy at like 300 pounds how
could one be happy does she not look
happy I think she looks the same TV I
don't know her personally so I but from
what I can see looks wise
yes okay okay so so one to ten you would
trade your body with hers
you said she had a good figure yeah dude
she would be offended if you said she
looks like lizzo would would you be
offended if I said you look fat
[Music]
no boobs
no I think if she wanted to she'd do it
she had those she was on Tick Tock like
on the treadmill I don't have Tick Tock
I don't you see a whole different side
of words
you gave her a 10. what's your metric
because she's confident with it
anybody that is confident I think yeah
women race with feeling not logic
it comes with with how you feel that's
what I can see I was big and I liked it
but it's a big small what made you like
it because I was different and I
couldn't I don't go gym I hate gym I
hate anything healthy I eat everything
not healthy but I liked it then I like
it now I and I'm very confident do you
know do you not think there's Universal
standards of beauty so when everyone
walks into the room where everyone can
kind of okay when everyone walks into
the room you don't think everyone has a
general perception of who's more
beautiful and less beautiful
I don't know these days no I'm not I'm
not talking about these days I mean in
general well
and okay even even take us in the room
you don't think most of us like they
could say who's more beautiful and less
beautiful and I'm not I'm not trying to
put us against each other I'm not saying
to be rated but like I'm saying like you
don't think in general you know who the
pretty friend in your friend group is I
think what she's doing she's she's
thinking of uh like you say always
women's perspective so if a man is a bit
ugly but he has a lot of confidence in
the woman's eye he becomes more yeah so
that's how women view other women okay
because she confident is more attractive
but men don't look at women like that
just because you're confident she
doesn't become more attractive actually
we see her wait you see her
how many points does confidence give a
woman
three points of fives
one yeah
don't you like a shy girl though I don't
mind a psycho men like shy gills no okay
lizzo so what would you rank Liza one to
ten zero okay what is she what is she
with confidence
still zero okay why yeah I assume here
because I feel like for me I don't
really think you have to be very good
looking or whatever but I think whatever
you've been given naturally you should
make the best of that that's what she's
doing no she's she's got fat
she wasn't bad
you think okay do you think women are
naturally fat no but do you think okay
so when he says do the best with what
you have naturally he's talking about
like being in shape and like you can't
change your face
but you you can get on the you know on
the treadmill but she maybe she doesn't
want to maybe she's happy I I don't
think maybe it could be or maybe she's
lazy I think she's lazy because they've
seen our um on treadmill on Instagram
but she she just doesn't have the yeah
you know things like overactive fire
rules underactive fight you can okay I'm
sorry go go into a poverty-stricken
country where are the overactive
thyroids
like now she just likes to eat a lot and
she's lazy like especially with her she
has no she's being lazy when she's a
performer just look at it no excuse me
maybe she's not lazy but she just eats
too much so no matter how active you are
if you eat more calories than you ban
you're fat so maybe she just yeah it's
like a form of lack of discipline and
self-control which is lazy you should
probably perform and then just eat ice
cream afterwards
the only reason she's striving is
because we're living in a whole Society
where you're trying to encourage women
to be you know plus size you know be
confident whatever if for example if
tomorrow she stopped getting gigs and
say Society doesn't like big women
anymore you see her slim down I've got a
question for you if you had a daughter
and she was little size
how would you feel about it
you take her to the doctors
wow yeah
family and friends who are that big I do
have family and friends and saying what
I said you wouldn't be concerned with
her oh wait if you had a daughter you
wouldn't try to like feed her last
exactly as a parent you can't be like oh
if that was your daughter well it's then
it's your fault yeah but she's an adult
it's different as a child
[Music]
yeah I don't know because because of my
parent doesn't mean I don't go to bed so
maybe when I'm I'm in bed they're busy
eating everything up so then lots of
cupboards
don't don't yeah it doesn't matter
because at some point you would see the
hurt increase so you will notice that
hold on a second why are you getting so
big so quickly how many how many how
many big women in your family like just
say just do you know any big women in
your family like lizzo there must be at
least one
two I know you said to them look I'm
concerned about your weight you need to
go doctor you think no listen to me
they're not his kids though that's
different
is they got big they got like that based
on their life choices
one of my family members actually lost a
lot of weight
a lot of weight
so there would have been some form of
encouragement stimulus into a into her
brain that said you know what this ain't
right for me and I have another family
member that actually wanted to do the
same but like pearly said oh also one
discipline wasn't there like nobody's
actually happy fat nobody they're always
trying to lose weight it's just she's
just accepted it I even I think she
might not be happy I even know guys
that'll say like oh I would date bigger
girls like I find them attractive but
but they're so insecure it's a headache
who sorry I've had guys like I I talked
to people I do this like four times a
week so I'm always like the in and out
and I've had guys say like I find bigger
girls attract probably not lizard side
they probably just mean like you know
yeah
but but they said they won't date them
because they are so insecure and they're
always like talking about their bot and
it's just annoying to them
well that's different then that's
because they're that's just they're
insecure well I'm saying like I don't
think fat people are actually confident
I just think they say that to themselves
to make themselves feel better but
they're not actually conscious if you're
not getting the same way of skinny
people like a really stuck cannot put on
weight as quick as they can with the
fast metallics I don't think it's the
same I'm sure yeah I don't think it's
the same so if you saw a skinny person
you said oh you look skinny today I
think most I think
a good amount of I won't say most but I
think there's a portion of guys that
don't that like if she's in shape it's
fine like I've had guys say I've asked
guys like would you prefer a BBL or just
a girl with no butt and they say no butt
really yeah yeah who wants a BBL that's
fake right that's not like yeah
I'm sure I'm sure the preference is like
you know the the goods or whatever yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but like like I mean
I'm just saying like I I think there's a
difference between someone who's skinny
with no butt and no boobs and someone
that's 300 pounds
I mean
she's just accepted she's fat and that's
the that's what that's the mindset we
need to change it's like you shouldn't
accept that you're far you know do
something about it do you know I think
it's the media as well that are telling
this this is what I'm saying
she's getting put on Vogue or whatever I
don't know but you know they basically
celebrating half a bit like that so yeah
putting fat chicks on model cut like I
missed the models that used to make me
feel slightly bad about myself
that's what they're there to do they're
they're that's they're supposed to do
they're supposed to be the epitome of
beauty what that's why they changed it
yeah but I don't know what that's two
extreme there's like two Extremes in
that really skinny or really obese with
the average people I'm not saying like
really skinny I'm saying really
beautiful they were quite skinny back in
the days you know why because they're
not really that beautiful in real life
yeah they've been very airbrushed yeah I
don't know so now they're trying to
lower it to more like actual Beauty I
don't know I've seen like the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show those girls are
beautiful
like I can't you can't tell me that you
can't tell me Kendall Jenner isn't
beautiful she's skinny really skinny no
she's pretty in her face what about plus
size models like I support them proper
plus size like 12 14 maybe 16. 12. UK
is 14.
sorry I'm from Lithuania maybe
you mean
like 18 20 all right we do plus 18 is
around 14 yeah maybe but not like 22
plus size that's you need to lose weight
if everything is in proportion then you
can get away with it but when you just
basically busting out the clothes you
know it's see exactly that's the thing
like whatever size you are accommodate
your body you can be even lizard-sized
no and still dress for your body you can
she doesn't have to come out if she
likes to come out in crop tops and just
show everything you don't have to what
about the health your health but some
people are oh it might be relatively
good health not at 300 pounds yeah
definitely not no maybe not her size but
bigger people can still be in relatively
like good health you can be real real
thin and have bad Health yeah but people
just associate oh you're thin you're
healthy yeah you're big you're unhealthy
unhealthy but actually it's not like
that well I think in general the thinner
pitiful tend to be healthier and the
fatter people tend to be not but if
you're too thin you're really not yeah
but come out come on okay okay what
percentage girls are really too thin
nowadays well I was from there were like
super thin yeah so but but here in the
west yeah no people aren't that thin
anymore yeah I think I don't think that
being too skinny is a problem and here
in the U.S
yeah in general some but in general not
really
not really
um okay I'm gonna take a second to read
super as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible